I told you in the last video that
epoxides are very reactive that this
this little triangle right here this
equilateral triangle is highly strained
highly unstable so it makes it want to
do something get out of this
configuration so what I want to do in
this video is to show you a reaction so
what we have right here and we saw this
in the last video I've drawn a couple
more hydrogen's and I've actually drawn
a little bit of the three-dimensional a
nature of the bonds right here because
it'll matter this is a cyclo and
remember you can just pretend like this
triangle here if it was replaced with a
double bond this would be cyclohexene
this would be cyclo cyclo cyclohexane
but because instead of a double bond
right here we have these bonds to this
oxygen this is cyclohexene oxide this is
cyclohexene oxide let's think about what
would happen if we had some cyclohexene
oxide mixed in with water and we have
some type of maybe acid catalyst in
there so it'd allow some extra hydrogen
protons to float around so we have water
but since we actually put some acid
catalyst there and it could really be
any acid catalyst anything that would
increase the hydrogen proton
concentration we're more likely to have
some hydronium ions floating around and
we know what hydronium ions look like
they look like water with an extra
proton with an extra hydrogen on them so
hydronium ions look like this this is
water let me do it in different colors
and sorry to use the blue for the
cyclohexene oxide so this is water right
here this is water right here but what
happens to get hydronium is the the
oxygen in the water takes a proton from
someplace else from some acid the acid
catalyst in this case and so it would
look like and it would essentially give
an electron to it if this was this
electron it gets given to some hydrogen
proton the ending result will look like
this will look like this you have a bond
formed with another hydrogen and now you
have a positive charge you have a
positive charge on the oxygen because it
gave away an electron
this is hydronium we've seen it many
times hydronium and this is what results
if you put an acid in water it will
increase the hydronium concentration
you'll see more and more of this
so what's likely to happen if we have
cyclohexene oxide in a water that with
water is a solvent but we also have a
good amount of hydronium floating around
and the more acid we put in the more
hydronium we'll have well a possible
reaction and you is well let's see this
oxygen is just as likely or it may want
to take get a hydrogen proton just as
much as a hydronium so if they bump into
each other in the exact right way this
oxygen right here could give an electron
to that hydrogen right there and then
the original this orange hydronium or
this orange oxygen right here can take
its electron back and if that happens
what do we end up with well let's see so
if that happened now we have let me draw
this original molecule it will no longer
be cyclohexene oxide exactly because it
just got a hydrogen proton it's an
intermediary now let me try my best to
draw it though all right we have that
then we have the oxygen popping out of
the page we have the oxygen popping out
of the page it had it had these two
extra electron pairs but now it gave one
of its electrons to this proton so now
it gave one of its electrons to this
hydrogen right here and I keep I call it
a proton because a hydrogen without an
electron is just a proton it doesn't
have another Neutron inside of the
nucleus so you have the hydrogen over
there
now since this oxygen gave away an
electron it now has a positive charge
let me draw these two purple hydrogen's
that are behind the page so that's one
hydrogen there one hydrogen there
obviously there's other hydrogen's on
these carbons but if I were to drew it
it would take a while it would make the
whole diagram messy but it's always
assumed that a neutral carbon will have
four bonds and of course this thing
right here is now just water this thing
took its electron back this thing took
its electron back I'll draw it here this
thing took its electron back and now
it's water it could be this one or maybe
it could you know that but
obviously tons of water around so I can
even draw other water molecules doesn't
have to just be that one now what is
likely to happen and this is kind of the
fun part of this of this reaction
because it's actually something you
we've seen before it's a reaction that
we've seen many many times already but
it's just not obvious when you see it in
this form when you look at this molecule
right here what is what's going on here
well I have I already told you that I
have this highly highly strained bond
here it's like this equilateral triangle
the bond angles are closer than they
want to be the electrons want to get
away from each other if you try to do
this with a chemistry model it would
actually strain the plastic or the wood
of the chemistry model to actually make
it on top of that this this height this
this oxygen was extra with this extra
hydrogen now it is actually a good
leaving group and so now it's probably
triggering some things in your brain
about the type of reaction that might
occur and think about this carbon right
here think about this carbon actually
these two carbons are the same so I'll
just pick on this one the bottom one for
fun think about this carbon right here
it is bonded it's a secondary carbon so
it's not you know it would not be super
great for an sn2 reaction but you can
have an sn2 reaction with a secondary
carbon especially when the leaving group
wants to leave bad enough so if one of
these water molecules I didn't have to
be this first one right here if it just
bumps into this carbon in the exact way
it can actually act as a nucleophile
water isn't traditionally a very strong
nucleophile but it can be a nucleophile
especially if the new if the leaving
group is ready to leave and this is a
really strained bond so what you could
imagine is is that the say this water
gives an electron it loves this carbon
nucleus right there it gives it to that
carbon and since that carbon is getting
an electron from this water over here
then it can release an electron back to
this oxygen making it neutral so it can
release this back to this oxygen right
here so what will what will we end up
with then now something interesting has
just happened and this is typical of all
sn2 reactions and remember it's sn2
we're substituting with
a nucleophile waters a weak nucleophile
but in this case its its it'll stick
better than this thing that's all
strained and we call it two sn2 because
both of the reactants are involved in
the rate-determining step this is the
rate determining step right here so what
do we end up with what do we end up with
so let me just draw the hexane ring just
like that now all of a sudden now all of
a sudden this oxygen this oxygen up here
what will it look like
well this bond gets broken it takes back
an electron it takes back an electron so
you only have this bond to the oxygen
this top bond to the oxygen that's the
oxygen right there
it took this electron back so now it has
this electron and the electron that was
bonded to the carbon so it has a pair of
electrons and then it's bonded to that
hydrogen that it took from the hydronium
in the first step and then it's bonded
to this hydrogen over there so it really
is just an OHA up now bonded right that
it's popping out of the page you still
have this hydrogen that's going behind
the page you still have this hydrogen
that's going behind the page but since
we had an sn2 reaction you can imagine
this kind of came from the back and this
let go from the front so what will now
happen is is this hydrogen that was kind
of behind the page now will pop forward
because this guy went from even behind
that hydrogen so this hydrogen over here
will now pop forward so this hydrogen
now has popped forward I'll Circle it
just so you see it's the same hydrogen
was popped forward since this guy this
nucleophile attack happened from the
back and now he is attached
he has attached down here this water has
attached what's not water anymore so you
had the oxygen two hydrogen's and then
it had two one it had two pairs but now
one of the pair turns into a bond
because it gives this electron there so
these two guys are bonded this electron
is given to the carbon and the bond is
behind the page now the bond is behind
the page just like that and then the
final step is now this guy since this
guy gave an electron he has a positive
charge here just to make it nice and
clean you could
imagine another water molecule another
water molecule comes and takes one of
those hydrogen's away from this guy it's
all these hydrogen's are just getting
passed around between between these
water molecules so you could imagine
this water molecule could take that
hydrogen the this oxygen takes the
electron back and then becomes neutral
and then our final product we are now
done will look like this
our final product so we had cyclohexene
oxide and a reactive epoxide in water
with some acid around so it kind of
catalyzed the leaving group and all that
we just saw that in this but what is the
resulting molecule look look like so
popping out of the page up here we have
we have an OHA
thats this right here I'm just
simplifying a little bit going behind
the page we have a hydrogen right over
there and then popping out of the page
we have a hydrogen so popping out of the
page right here we have a hydrogen and
then behind the page we have another o H
group Beyond behind the page we have
another Oh H group so we've made a dial
and in particular if we wanted to name
this thing right here this is we have
our second cyclohexane ring that's our
main ring so let's call that so we have
cyclo cyclo hexane and then we have OAH
groups on though we could just start
numbering we want to start numbering at
the where the groups are so we call this
two one two three four five six carbon
we have Oh H groups at the one and the
two carbons so we have two of them so
it's a dial so we call this 1 comma 2 1
comma 2 dial because we have two AOH
groups die all that's the all is for
alcohol when you have these O age groups
we have two of them and they are on
opposite sides this alcohol is or this
Oh H is popping out of the page this o
is behind the page so if we really
wanted to be specific about even the
stereochemistry here we would call this
trans they're on opposite sides ones in
front ones behind so this is trans this
is trans cyclohexane one to dial so
hopefully enjoy that but what
the fun thing about this is one to see
that epoxides are reactive did you just
even see a new reaction but the really
fun thing to see is that this these sn2
reactions keep popping up in fact the
ones we learned sn2 sn1 e1 e2 these just
keep over and over just popping up in
chemistry in places that you maybe it
wasn't obvious when you look at it you
know at the first glance but then when
you actually think about it it's
actually perfect for that type of
reaction